Salut à tous, c'est Pêcheur de Trésor. Alors aujourd'hui on est sous un pont dans une petite ville.
Un pont qui a l'air bien sympa et bien passant et l'aimant de Quentin est déjà sur quelque chose.
Donc ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on le remonte tout de suite et qu'on ne vous casse pas la tête avec une intro d'une heure.
Allez, c'est parti !
On va mettre le gant quand même pour éviter de se blesser.
Ouais, toujours mettre des gants, surtout que c'est des clous et c'est de la rouille.
Donc c'était sous le pont.
C'est étonnant parce que cet endroit est fait normalement, peut-être que c'est un objet récent.
Oh ! D'accord.
Ok, déjà il y a des traces, ça a été fait mais pas complètement
Chaîne de vélo.
Ouais, pas à 1000% quoi
Et bien sûr on est en compagnie de Rasta qui est pas trop en forme
Il a une copine chien qui vient de partir prendre le train alors il est un peu triste.
Il va nous faire comme Hatchie et il va retourner à la gare tous les jours.
C'est ça.
Mais la température ça fait plaisir là, on est en plein été et pourtant il fait bon.
Ouais, tu dirais combien en température ressenti et température d'eau ?
D'eau, je sais pas encore d'eau mais je vais finir mouillé comme d'habitude
On attends que tu tombes dedans, c'est pour ça que j'ai sorti le maillot.
Ouais, il est directement au maillot avec ce magnifique temps.
Il est encore dans le sud pour ceux qui se demandent.
C'est juste que ça peut arriver de temps en temps.
Ok, bon bah, c'est un bout de canette.
Ouais, c'est pas vide vide
Il y a une pièce là.
Un centime d'euros.
Ah, c'est le début de la richesse.
Ouais.
Ah bah non.
Eh bah voilà.
Ah, y a quelque chose.
Oh !
Ok.
Donc déjà on a une pile.
Donc ça, bien pour la dépollution.
Une pédale de vélo.
Ah bah y en a des choses.
Ok, une clé plate.
Dans son plastique d'origine.
Outillage professionnel
garantie à vie.
Garantie à vie, ok.
Ben ouais, bah on va le renvoyer.
Il va dire, il va dire.
Tu leurs dis "j'ai eu un problème".
J'ai eu un problème.
Je sais pas ce qui s'est passé.
Elle était bien, et puis d'un coup...
Allez, on garde ça, c'est ce qu'on garde dans le saut.
Là tout à l'heure, j'ai pas filmé.
Mais ça, c'est peut-être une météorite encore.
Elle est très aimantée, très dense.
On verra, à étudier.
Allez, on continue.
Encore un lancer.
Très très très très nul.
Là pour l'instant, y a Baptiste qui tchatche avec les abonnées.
Pendant que je pêche.
C'est pas une abonnée.
Bon, ça va.
Alors il a le droit, on va dire.
Allez, premier lancer pour ma part.
J'ai rejoint la partie un petit peu après Quentin.
Et là, j'espère faire des découvertes.
Ce qui vont vraiment le démoraliser et lui dire.
Et lui dire, voilà.
Quentin, c'est qui le patron aujourd'hui de la pêche à l'aimant
Allez, voyons voir ce qu'on a.
Oh, un petit rasoir.
Celui-là, je ne m'en servirai pas.
On a aussi une petite pièce de 2 centimes et une pièce de 1 centime.
Et bah écoutez, on continue avec les petites pièces.
C'est toujours drôle à trouver.
Allez, j'ai quelque chose, un bon poids.
Oh, plusieurs choses.
Ah non, c'est un phare.
Ou un réveil.
Regarde, c'est un réveil, je crois.
Un réveil ancien.
Tu sais, tu appuies au dessus
Ouais, on dirait, ouais.
Ouais, c'est un réveil.
C'est sympa, ouais.
Belle trouvaille.
Et...
Ouais, non, c'est très beau parce qu'il n'est pas jeune.
Ouais.
Bien joué.
Ah ça, c'est...
C'est le lundi matin quand tu peux t'implomber.
Tu le jettes au canal.
Là, il y a encore un gros truc, ici, là.
Ouais, ça se lève.
Ça se lève, ça se lève.
Quelques kilos.
Un panneau.
Ouais, il n'est pas vieux, là.
Alors, c'est quoi, celui-là ?
Ok.
Ah, il est bien, lui.
Oui, celui-là.
On va le mettre en place, hein.
Comme ça, on nous laissera tranquille.
Voilà, un travaux en cours.
Je crois que j'ai vu quelque chose qui était bien au milieu.
Ouais.
Tu es prêt, mon petit Quentin ?
Oui, il y a des bulles
Ouais.
Celui-là, il m'attendait, hein.
C'est un fusil ?
Non.
Attends.
Un bombe ?
Non
Une roquette ?
C'est creux
ça a l'air ancien
C'est un pieux selon moi
Je pense que c'est...
Non, il est creux.
Vu la couleur chromée qu'on a ici,
je pense que c'est plus un morceau
de peau d'échappement d'une moto.
Il doit être bien ancien, hein.
Une mobilette, sûrement.
Oh, un gros morceau qui vient.
il n'était pas loin du peau d'échappement,
donc peut-être que c'est un bout de la mobilette.
C'est un caddie ?
Il y a un sac avec un sac.
C'est le haut d'un caddie ?
On commence par...
Regardez ce qu'il y a dans le sac.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans le sac ?
Ouais, il est tellement...
Dans les bâtons, là.
Voilà, le sac est vide.
Rasta, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Voilà, Rasta s'est fait un copain.
Enfin, pour l'instant,
c'est pas encore un copain, mais...
Allez, qu'est-ce qu'on a ici ?
Oh, une petite cuillère !
Parfait, là, en bon état, en plus.
Regardez-le, ce coquin.
Il est en train de la monter.
Oh, un briquet !
Rasta in love !
Rasta in love, regardez.
Ça tombe... Ça tombe parfaitement bien.
C'est pas beau, ça ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on a ici ?
Il y a de la vieille chose.
Oh, une montre !
C'est vraiment de la montre bas de gamme.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette montre ?
Water resistant, goodby, goodbye.
Ok, bon, c'est nul.
Mais ça reste une montre.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on a de beau ?
Oulah !
Qu'est-ce que c'est ça ?
Baptiste !
Un plug en forme de pommes de pain ?
Ouais, c'est sur le haut des portails, je pense.
On dirait une pomme de pain, non ?
Ouais, je pense que tu vois le haut d'un portail.
J'aime bien.
En vrai, c'est stylé.
Tu peux te le mettre dans les fesses mais je ne pense pas que ce soit fait pour
Ouais, mais je le garde, ça.
Oh, et ça, c'est une munition,
Une ogive
de kar98, je crois.
Elle est blindée, elle est aimantée ?
Elle est, ouais, elle est aimantée.
Sympa, un peu de militariat.
J'ai eu quelque chose, regarde les bulles
J'espère que ce n'est pas un autre morceau du caddie,
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a remonté le haut.
Oh, sympa !
Une petite trotte et une pédale de vélo en plus
Ouais.
Ok, la trottinette, c'est de l'aluminium, la trotte, c'est cool.
Tu crois ?
Ouais, il n'y a que cet endroit-là où il y a de l'acier.
J'allais dire justement comment on a pu passer à côté de ça
en lançant l'aimant 15 fois
Sympa.
Elle est en allume.
Belle trouvaille.
Merci.
Ryanair.
Je pense qu'il y a des abonnés dans la rue
qui peuvent nous reconnaître.
Ouais, peut-être, ouais.
J'aime bien cet endroit
mais il manque un peu de bonne trouvaille.
Non, mais il y en aura, je pense qu'il en reste sous la vase
Bon, là, je retourne les trucs.
Ouais, il en reste.
Il y a plein de bois, mais...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Regarde-moi ça.
Mais tu vois, là-dessous, après,
on peut choper plein de choses.
C'est ça une fois qu'on a enlevé ça.
Il y a une sacoche.
Ah ouais.
Une banane.
Elle est ouverte, malheureusement.
Ah, ils ont tout vidé
Ouais.
Alors, on va continuer à suivre la nouvelle tradition.
Je prends la casquette.
Je retourne la casquette.
Et j'ai quelque chose de bien au bout de l'aimant
Il était là-bas...
À droite?
Ouais.
Et il a un poids correct.
Oh, oh, oh.
Un bloc d'acier
C'est pas une météorite, ça?
Non.
C'est de la fonte?
Alors, ça, c'est super dense.
Des fois, ça peut être des résidus d'explosion
pendant la guerre d'Obu ou de bombe,
ou même vraiment du métal qui a subi des fortes contraintes.
Parce que là, c'est vraiment étonnant.
C'est super dense.
Bon.
Tu veux le peser?
Regarde-la.
Ouais.
C'est bon pour le faire ailleurs.
Je pense pas que c'est une météorite.
Non.
Dommage.
Médallion.
Ouais, médaillon.
Peut-être un truc pour le caddie.
Ouais, c'est une jeton de caddie.
Tu le cherchais tout à l'heure.
Ouais, peut-être que c'est celui-là.
Oh, regarde!
Une munition à blanc, couleur blanche.
C'est rigolo, elle est en plastique.
Ah, c'est...
D'entraînement.
C'est pour famas non ?
Ouais, je pense.
Intéressant.
Non, mais gardez-le, ça, c'est sympa.
Oui.
On le met avec...
Attends, mets ça avec.
Ça, c'est fait pour tirer, ouais, tirer à blanc.
Ouais, de manipulation.
Manipulation, c'est ça.
C'est même pas tirer, c'est manipuler, ouais.
Ouais.
Bon, si vous êtes abonnés et que vous reconnaissez votre chien, on s'excuse.
Et vous pouvez garder les bébés.
C'est les bébés du youtubeur, ils valent très chère
Oh!
Ah dommage elle est ouverte
Tu veux la rasade?
C'est la Fisher
Euh...
Oui.
Oui on reconnaît Fisher
Moi, j'ai une pile qui a été écrasée.
Ah, la belle dépollution.
Merci
Une petite pièce, ça fait toujours plaisir
Ça va Rasta ?
T'as une nouvelle copine?
Oh, ça brille.
Oh oui, une lame de couteau.
Et pas n'importe quel couteau, il est magnifique.
Wow, regardez-moi ces couleurs.
Sympa.
Est-ce qu'il est bien aiguisé ?
Regardez.
Pas mal, pas mal.
Bah ça, c'est restaurable.
C'est plus qu'à trouver un manche.
On va voir ce qu'on arrive à choper sous ce pont.
Ohoohohohoh !
C'est fou ça
Il font des bêtises, hein.
C'est fou ce qu'il se passe aujourd'hui.
Il y a Jason, Statham en haut du pont
Il va venir, il va te péter la gueule.
Alors là, j'ai trouvé ça avec un M.
C'est assez dense.
Je ne saurais pas dire ce que c'est si vous avez une idée en commentaire.
Ouais, le plus pré-possible du bord.
Je ne sais pas si j'ai quelque chose, si c'est le bord
Oh oui !
Alors ça, c'est une enceinte.
Une enceinte JBL.
Elles résistent pas  à l'eau ?
Jusqu'à un certain niveau peut-être, mais...
Ah oui, en plus, tu as le truc.
Si, si, si, peut-être.
A tester, hein.
Ouais, ça se tente.
En tout cas, si vous voulez pêcher des enceintes JBL comme nous,
n'hésitez pas à aller voir le site de Maison de la Detection
avec le code promo Pêcheur de Trésor,
qui offre 5% sur toute la boutique.
Nous, on utilise l'aimant Barbarian
Ouais, c'est le meilleur aimant du marché.
Il a une force de 1600 kilos,
et il pèse environ 1 kilo 5 à 2 kilos
C'est ça.
Mais pour commencer, on conseille le terror.
Ça fait déjà bien l'affaire.
Il faut assurer, parce que là, le match au Tinder,
il va me demander ce qu'on a pêché.
Tu vas te calmer, oui ?
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on a ?
On a une télécommande de portail,
à nom de voiture.
Ou de portail, à nom de voiture.
Une Nissan, Quentin
Tiens.
Une petite Nissan.
En vrai, pour l'instant,
la meilleure trouvaille, c'est le chien noir.
Ça se vend cher, ça.
On s'est décalé un petit peu plus loin du pont
pour un endroit qui ne sera pas fait, sûrement.
On va regarder ce qu'on a.
Bah ouais, voilà.
Déjà, c'est des plus gros objets,
et c'est des objets anciens, donc...
Donc, c'est intéressant.
Alors ?
Yes !
Qu'est-ce que c'est, ça, Quentin ?
Je fais quelque chose ?
Oh oui, un cœur
Ah, c'est beau.
Ouais ?
Oh, il a écrit quelque chose !
Regarde, regarde.
Ah, un vélo !
Bien joué !
C'est sympa, il est en bon état
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
On va pouvoir le tester
Oui, je pense que ça se test
Ok.
Belle trouvaille
Bah moi, il y a marqué un sur mon cœur
Quand même, attends.
On va essayer de le nettoyer
Louis...
Pas...
Bon, j'arrive pas à déchiffrer.
Tu es prêt ?
Il s'appelle comment ?
Il faut lui donner un nom.
Ouais, il faut lui donner un nom, On va l'appeler Jépéto
Allez, Jépéto
Allez, Jépéto boit
Pardon, Jépéto tu as eu peur
Alors...
J'ai juste eu un petit couvercle de boîte de sardine
Ok.
Pas fou.
C'est un téléphone ?
Ouais, pas sûr.
Ah, GPS, attends.
Une calculatrice ?
GPS, ouais.
Ouais.
Navon.
Sympa.
C'est original.
Donc là, regardez,
je viens de faire un très vieux couteau.
Sympa.
Ouais.
On va voir si j'ai mieux au bout de l'aimant
Oh mince
C'est un portefeuille.
Ah oui, porte monnaie.
Ouais.
Prêt pour l'ouverture ?
il est aimanté à l'intérieur,
donc j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des pièces,
ou alors c'est...
Ah, c'est peut-être le tour qui est aimanté
Il tombe en miettes attends.
Si, il y a des pièces,
c'est peut-être des francs,
vu la date.
Regarde ça.
Ah oui, il y a des pièces.
Une carte.
Wow.
Elle doit être vieille, celle-là.
Une clé.
Américaine tourister
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Bog Luggage
Là, c'est un bijou.
Ah ouais ?
Et la pièce, je la trouve plus.
Elle y était t'es sûr ?
Ah si, oui, il y avait une pièce.
Elle est là.
Ah bah attends.
C'est de l'euro ?
Ah non.
Non, c'est du franc.
Non, non, non, non, non.
Pfennig.
Ah, c'est les Pennigs, c'est allemand.
C'est allemand, ouais.
Ouais.
Ok.
1984.
World Kreber, c'est son nom ?
Ouais.
Et son adresse ?
Ouais, World Kreber.
Milwaukee.
Donc c'est aux États-Unis, hein.
Carrément.
Je crois, ouais.
Incroyable, en vrai.
Montre le moi
Donc des sous allemandes.
Une adresse aux États-Unis.
Il y a quelqu'un qui s'est fait un voyage en Europe.
Faudrait qu'on regarde si on le trouve sur...
C'est peut-être énorme de le trouver la personne.
Sur Facebook ou quoi, ouais.
C'est un nom allemand, quand même, non ?
Grubber ?
Ouais, c'est un normalement, ouais.
Milwaukee.
Ouais, c'est aux États-Unis, hein, l'adresse, ouais.
C'est fou de trouver ça ici, ouais.
C'est incroyable.
On va regarder l'adresse sur Google Maps,
pour vous met l'endroit où habiter cette personne.
Ouais.
Ça peut être très drôle.
Très loin d'ici, en tout cas.
Ouais, c'est fou.
Bah, belle trouvaille, hein.
C'est cool, avec la petite pièce de souvenir, là.
Ouais.
Il est tellement resté dans l'eau avec la carte.
Est-ce que ça a imprimé la carte sur le...
Ah, oui, oui.
Sur le papier.
Hop.
Oh, boulet de canon.
Hum.
C'est bizarre, c'est bleuté.
Ah, non, alors.
Mais attends, secoue
Un grelot de pêche ?
Enfin une sorte de grelot
Le son est super
C'est peut-être pour la pêche.
Est-ce que vous l'entendez sur la GoPro ?
Bon.
Si vous savez ce que c'est en commentaire.
Ouais.
Regarde, c'est lancé.
Hop.
Nul.
Allez, on continue toujours à cet endroit,
qui réserve quand même des surprises, visiblement.
Ah, mince, je me suis accroché au bord.
C'est un morceau de roue de vélo,
donc il n'y avait pas qu'un seul vélo.
Et j'ai aperçu quelque chose tout à l'heure, là,
par là.
Est-ce qu'il va venir ?
Ah ouais, ouais, ouais.
En plus, tu sais quoi ?
On peut le garder, celui-là.
Et oui, à la maison, ils sont tous cassés.
Ouais, attends.
Impécable, ça.
Voilà.
Comment trouver un balai gratuitement dans le canal,
c'était le tutoriel de Pêcheur de Trésor.
Et on se dit à très vite pour un nouveau tutoriel
de Pêcheur de Trésor,
avec cette fois-ci la recherche d'un aspirateur.
Troisième endroit visité,
juste à côté du pont où on a commencé,
on est passé de l'autre côté cette fois-ci.
Je viens à peine de jeter mon aimant là-bas au fond,
et j'ai déjà quelque chose qui vient.
Oh, suspense.
Ça se soulève.
Quentin, j'ai besoin de ton aimant.
On dirait qu'il y a du bois,
ça peut être un truc cool.
C'est assez lourd, donc essayer de le jeter plus devant.
Je crois que c'est une sorte de piqué.
Attends.
C'est bizarre, la forme.
C'est un poteau.
C'est de l'aluminium ?
Ah, c'est grand.
Ah, c'est un panneau.
Je m'attendais à mieux.
Il y a une laisse de chien accrochée
C'est les laisses que tu peux rétracter là.
C'est cool.
Où est le caniche ?
Belle trouvaille
Ouais, c'est...
Le parking comme ça, c'est quoi ?
Le parking payant.
C'est pas de l'aluminium, c'est un alliage un peu spécial.
Tu as vu, c'est rare de le choper par là le panneau.
D'habitude, c'est le coincer là-dessus à la limite.
T'as réussi à le tirer comme ça.
Ouais, choper le panneau là.
Il n'était pas dans la vase
Ok.
Ah oui.
Ah oui, quand même.
Pas juste ok.
Des munitions de calibre 12.
Enfin non, peut-être pas 12, c'est peut-être du 16.
Numéro 6.
70.
Max 1050 barres.
Elles sont pas françaises.
Intéressant, intéressant, intéressant.
Donc c'est non, c'est pas du 12, c'est plus petit.
On va les mettre là.
Et on va tirer l'aimant de nouveau
Parce que du coup, c'est intéressant.
Ce qui est bizarre, c'est que je sais plus trop
ou j'avais tiré.
Vers là.
On va voir.
Un petit fusil, ça ferait plaisir.
Je dirais pas non.
Ouais.
Oh, un outil.
Alors ça, c'est un marteau d'ardoisier, il me semble.
Il est totalement en fer, donc c'est sympa.
C'est surtout bien ancien.
Ça, c'est de la découverte que j'aime bien.
100% fer.
Donc ouais.
Difficile à dater, mais très ancien.
J'ai un objet.
Pas très gros, mais ça vient.
On va regarder tout de suite ce que c'est.
Je n'ai pas réussi à retrouver une munition.
C'est bizarre qu'il n'y en ait que deux, mais bon.
Elle est pleine.
Ça, c'est trop bien.
J'ai soif.
Oh non.
Elle est pleine, tiens.
Ouais, mais non, merci.
Regardez, Gepetto, il s'est mis plein de boules.
Et moi aussi, ça fait mal aux jambes
C'est chiant.
En plus, pour les enlever, ça arrache les poils.
Donc, ouais.
Pas cool, ça, pas cool.
Rasta, reste sur le chemin, c'est bien.
Allez.
Allez, allez, allez.
Allez, le trousseau de clé, ça, c'est pas jeune.
Ça, c'est vraiment tout ce qui a été perdu un petit moment.
Sympa.
Alors, ça y est.
Ça y est.
Il a été retrouvé.
Ouais.
Donc il faut savoir qu'il est recherché depuis ce matin.
Et du coup, c'est même pas grâce à nous, parce qu'il n'est pas de collier ni rien,
mais le monsieur l'a reconnu.
Il est plein de boules.
J'ai une énergumène qui ressemble à ton chien sur le bord du canal, c'est pas à toi.
Ah ouais, avec plaisir.
Alors là, j'ai attrapé quelque chose dans le canal.
J'y vais doucement pour pas qu'il s'échappe
Là, tu nous fais un petit remake de Man vs Wild.
Ouais.
Alors, c'est un plein mieux.
J'espère que c'est intéressant.
Ça vient encore, ouais.
Oui.
Alors là, pour savoir, on s'est un petit peu décalé d'endroit.
On est toujours dans la même ville.
Ça a l'air plutôt dense.
Ouais, ça bulle.
Wow, une chaise.
Elle n'est même pas aimantée, non ?
Une chaise en osier.
En plastique.
C'est légèrement aimanté, là où t'es, là ?
Ouais, peut-être un peu.
Ok.
Bon, c'est drôle.
Alors, j'ai fait quelque chose les enfants.
Vous êtes prêts à être subjugés,
devant une trouvaille de qualité.
Ah, si, 5 centimes ?
Ouais, 5 centimes.
En vrai, des pièces ici, c'est pas des vœux.
Il y a peut-être une caisse, quelque part.
Ouais, peut-être.
Parce que j'en ai fait une aussi, là, tout à l'heure.
Là, j'ai mis là, le feu.
Donc, ça peut être bon signe.
Je pense qu'il y aura une caisse.
On garde de l'espoir.
En plus, quand tu as mangé un cassoulet,
donc dans tous les cas, il y aura des caisses aujourd'hui.
Mais moi, je préférerais qu'elle soit dans le canal.
C'est vrai.
J'ai mangé un cassoulet avant d'aller pêcher.
C'est vraiment un assassinat.
Ouais, mais ça va.
Ça devrait être interdit.
On est en extérieur.
Ah ouais, on est en extérieur.
Heureusement, le retour en camion, là.
Encore une pièce ?
Ouais, 5 centimes.
5 centimes, encore.
C'est pas ta caisse, ça, hein ?
Ouais, ouais.
Je pense que t'es pas loin de la caisse.
Salut !
J'ai eu quelque chose, mais juste au bord.
Juste là.
Oh, il y a un sacré poids
Il y a quoi ?
Le poids.
Allez, montre que tu fais de la bonne gonflette.
Ça fait une tonne 600
Il est coincé dans les herbes
Ah, c'est bon, tu arrives.
Ça, c'est de la trouvaille de merde.
Ah ouais, vraiment, hein.
Ah, bravo, quand même.
Munition de calibre 12.
Pleine.
Ça devient intéressant.
Et une fourchette aussi, en bon état.
Comme ça, dans le saut des trouvailles qu'on garde.
Oh, une montre !
Elle a pris l'eau.
Elle est morte.
Vous voyez, même pas la marque, elle a pris l'eau, mais bon.
Ça reste sympa.
Une montre, c'est une montre.
Regardez-moi ce bel endroit.
Des jetons de Casino
Oh, sympa.
C'est des rues, je crois, regarde.
Grimo 5 ?
Ouais.
Celui-là peut-être pas, mais celui-là...
Ça, c'est ce qu'on achète dans les mallettes.
Celui-là, je sais pas.
Ok.
Oh non, la quantité d'agrafes !
C'est une dinguerie
C'est un piège
À quel moment ?
Je sais pas, c'est terrible.
Rasta ! Baptiste a eu quelque chose.
Allez.
Je dédie cette trouvaille à Rasta
Même s'il n'est pas très sage aujourd'hui.
Mais regarde comme il est mignon, il baille.
Voilà, il se couche.
Allez.
Pas du bois j'espère
Des fusées éclairantes
Ça faisait longtemps.
Là, il y a moyen qu'elle fonctionne en plus.
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais.
Bon, il faudra tester le soir.
Ouais.
C'est grave stylé.
C'est sympa, ouais.
Elles ont pris l'eau quand même.
Je vais les ouvrir, dans tout le cas, on va enlever l'eau.
C'est censé résister un peu à l'eau, ouais.
Regarde, regarde.
Viens, viens voir.
On va voir leur état de conservation, malgré l'eau.
L'idée, c'est que ce sac-là, déjà, il devait être étanche, je pense, normalement.
Ouais.
La première barrière a échouée.
Mais ensuite, même une fois, une fois ouvert.
Même une fois ouvert, je pense que...
Oui, c'est censé résister à l'eau, encore.
Plastimo, signal à main rouge.
Bon ben, on testera ça.
Ouais.
Allez.
On continue, on s'est décalé un petit peu.
On va voir ce qu'on arrive à trouver ici.
Sous le pont, c'était effectivement déjà bien fait par d'autres pêcheurs à l'aimant.
Donc, autant se décaler.
Et on voit tout de suite que, dès qu'on s'écarte des ponts,
on a quand même pas mal de choses.
Alors là, j'ai fait un petit anti-vol de vélo et une pédale.
Bon, il est même pas cassé, il est juste tombé d'un bateau.
Hop.
Et le petit Rasta, il est toujours là.
Ça va, Rasta ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Oh, la proto !
Ben, bizarrement, on n'en n'avait pas trouvé aujourd'hui.
Des pinces à linges aussi, j'en trouve de toutes les couleurs.
Et un leurre de pêche
qui est bien mangé, mais qui avait de beaux yeux.
Là, regardez ce que j'ai.
J'espère ne pas le perdre.
Eh oui, le petit téléphone de dealer.
Classique.
Ça fait toujours plaisir,
parce qu'on sait qu'avec les aimants Barbarian
on peut avoir ce genre de choses,
que les petits aimants ratent
C'est cool.
Et une pile en plus pour la dépollution.
Et une bouteille de protoxide d'azote.
C'est cool, c'est cool, c'est cool.
Hop, le petit anti-vol.
Encore une fois, il est fermé.
On a un bout quand même.
Oh, jamais vu ça.
Cartouche de CO2.
Un mec qui a confondu avec le protoxyde d'azote
Dites-nous en commentaire,
à quoi ça sert ce type de cartouche de CO2.
Elle n'a pas l'air vide.
Un leurre de pêche, mais il n'y a plus d'hamecon
J'ai eu quelque chose,
Vous êtes prêt ?
Stylé !
C'est quoi ?
C'est une lime.
Elle est énorme
Elle est belle
Tu peux t'en servir de poignard.
Attention au vélo.
Allez, désenvase le
Essaye un peu seul
A deux, progressivement.
Comme ça, on ne fait pas trop d'accouts.
C'est bon, ça bulle, regarde
Il va venir.
Si il bulle comme ça, c'est qu'il va venir.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner un petit coup de main ?
Allez.
Je pense qu'il nous manque pas grand-chose pour le faire bouger.
Un, deux, trois.
C'est un beau poisson.
On va aller chercher le treuil.
Ça bulle bien.
Ça bulle en plus.
T'as l'impression que ça va venir
C'est lourd.
Ouais, c'est lourd.
On va prendre le treuil.
On va le mettre à l'arbre.
Qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être ?
C'est la question.
C'est pour ça qu'on ne peut pas partir.
On n'a pas réussi, même avec de l'aide,
donc on a ramené le tirs forts, 2 tonnes.
On va attacher à cet arbre.
Ça va être juste pour le désenvaser,
parce que ce tirs fort-là, il n'a qu'à 1,5 m de câble.
Ouais, ça devrait suffire.
On va tendre le piège à vélo.
Allez, c'est parti.
Fais moi buller cet objet.
Justement, là, on est bien.
Voilà, du coup, on a foutu ça en plein milieu.
J'espère qu'il n'y aura pas de vélo.
Ça bulle, ouais.
Mais ça a dû le désenvaser, là.
Ça vient ?
Ouais, ça vient.
À deux, je pense qu'on le sort.
Ça y est ?
Ouais, ça y est.
Oh, le poids.
Je retourne la casquette pour que ce soit un truc bien.
OK.
Enfin.
Voilà, enfin.
Après, au moins une demi-heure de galère, là.
Ouais, plus d'une heure.
Arrêtes ...
Plus d'une heure.
Un vrai marseillais
Très dur.
Oh le poids ! Attends
Carrément ?
Ouais.
Je film sur la casquette, on va le soulever à deux.
C'est le plaque d'égout tu crois ?
Ouais, les gars, c'est super lourd.
Il y a au moins 30 kg ou 40 kg.
Ah ouais.
Oh, c'est de la fonte.
Ouais.
Oh, le machin.
C'est une IPN, là.
Attends,
Attends deux secondes
Il y a un truc qui me bloque.
Ouais, ça, là.
Ouais, ouais.
Bien joué.
Tout ça pour ça.
Ah, là, celui-là.
Ah, c'est un bon morceau de fonte après, hein.
C'est de la fonte pure, hein.
Ouais.
Je ne sais pas comment ça pèse, mais...
Je sais pas. Bien joué.
Bien joué.
Et si vous savez ce que c'est, dis que nous, on dirait une sorte d'aileron
Ouais, c'est aileron, mais...
C'est peut être morceau péniche
Mais pourquoi c'est si lourd ?
Ça va la faire couler, la péniche.
Allez, je me casse.
Bon, on va peser l'objet.
Allez.
Je suis presque tombé en arrière
113.
Donc, t'enlèves 4 à 50, ça fait 46.
On n'était pas très loin
Ouais, c'est pas mal.
T'avais raison, t'avais dit plus de 40.
Ouais, je pensais entre 40 et 50, c'était ma théorie.
Ca a été soudé à la main, ouais.
Ouais, c'est une belle pièce, hein.
Ça doit coûter cher, sur mesure.
Ouais, vraiment, si ça appartient à un bateau, ça peut être intéressant.
Un gros gouvernail en fonte
On va peut-être le garder, ouais.
On espère que vous avez apprécié cette vidéo.
Nous, comme d'habitude, on va récupérer toute la ferraille qu'on a remontée aujourd'hui.
Elle sera vendu chez un ferrailleur
Et voilà, pas mal de découvertes insolites aujourd'hui.
On n'a pas eu d'énormes trouvailles.
On espère que la semaine prochaine, on aura un petit peu plus de chance.
D'ici là, portez-vous bien.